ANU SRIVASTAVA: Today, we're
talking about the Data Cloud
Summit, Google Chronicle,
"VM End to End,"
and startup guides.
I'm Anu.
And welcome to "This
Week in Cloud,"
where we serve you the
lowest latency news.
Organizations across
all industries
have gravitated
to Google's tools
for building data clouds because
of our speed, scale, security,
and our long-standing
leadership in AI.
If anyone has seen
firsthand how data
can transform businesses
and industries,
it's our partners and customers.
And next month, you can too.
Get the perspective
and insight you
need to turn your
organization into a data
powerhouse at the Data
Cloud Summit on April 6.
Register today.
We are thrilled to announce
the public preview of context
aware detections in
Google Chronicle.
With this release, we
are creating efficiencies
in every step of a customer's
detection and response journey,
starting by making alerts
more functionally enabled.
Check out the blog
for more details.
We publish another episode
of "VM End to End,"
which is a series of curated
conversations between a VM
skeptic and a VM enthusiast.
Every episode, join Brian,
Carter, and a special guest
as they explore why VMs
are some of Google's most
trusted and reliable offerings.
See how virtual machines
benefit companies operating
at scale in the Cloud.
Check out the episode and
transcript in the blog.
At Google Cloud, we want to
provide you with the access
to all the tools you need
to grow your business.
The Google Cloud technical
guides for Startups
leverages
industry-leading solutions
with how-to video guides and
resource handbooks curated just
for startups.
The multi series
contains three chapters,
start, build and grow, to match
your startup's stage of growth.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment
or tweet at us.
We'll see you in the Cloud.